I know that,
I know,
I'm just saying it's fucking.
I mean they fuck up all the time.
It's brutal,
but it's always live on it.
Always goes to itunes in the unedited
forum.
We just have to reboot it.
It's back up now.
Okay.
Um,
so where were you,
um,
natural disasters,
natural disasters?
So I think what we're,
you know,
it's,
it's basically we can see where we're
going right at the moment.
There's more and more natural disasters
coming faster and faster.
Some of that may be because of the fact
that we're going through a whole solar
system wide transition as scientists
like Dimitria from Russia talks about in
this guy dieter borrows,
some of it may be because the level of
human consciousness is more meshed with
the natural state of the planet than we
actually can comprehend quite yet,
which is what most of the indigenous
people believe.
And I've been visiting,
like we've been doing retreats down in
Columbia to work with the Kogi Indians
and they walk like 25 hours down from
the mountains to hang out with us.
And that's basically the message that
they've been giving us from,
from their,
from their older understanding of the
nature of reality,
you know,
it's somehow the level of human
spiritual development and how much we
are in a reciprocal relationship to our
local world,
you know,
has an effect on what type of
catastrophe is,
do or don't occur.
That's their perspective.
So,
uh,
when the earth is sick,
it's because we're sick and we're all
sick along with it.
So as tsunamis and hurricanes and
earthquakes and ultimately shifts in the
polar ice caps and shit like that,
and super volcanoes and yellowstone that
are ready to blow and kill half the shit
on the continent that,
that is all in correspondence with the
sickness of this species of us.
That's,
that's the indigenous perspective.
Tam.
That's a scary thought.
But listen,
man,
if we look at the ideas of quantum
physics that even observing something
with certain intentions can actually
change the outcome of particles.
You know,
when they do those tests,
those slot tests,
and they show that observing and
experiments actually observing
experience actually has an effect on the
result of the experiment.
Or,
or you could say there's no such thing
as just being an impartial observer.
You're always participating in,
in the outcome.
That's a better way of looking at it.
It really does make sense that it,
it,
it operates on macro micro and
ultimately,
you know,
this one gigantic level,
right?
Which is what like Western alchemists
talk about when they said as above,
so below
fucking crazy.
Is it the idea that human behavior can
actually inspire storms?
You know,
you don't want to say that because you
don't want to say that.
Like the most fucked up places.
The places get the storms,
but I used to do jokes about it.
They're cruel jokes that I would never
do now,
but I just do jokes about how tornadoes
were attracted to the smell of white
trash.
They just circle when you have too much
macaroni and cheese and,
and 40 ounce beer in one location,
but it's a terrible idea.
There's a terrible joke.
It's,
it's really cruel to think that you're
cooler than these fucking poor people
that live in some place where the sky
becomes an angry monster.
But it is kind of
weird that they only landed fucked up
places.
You don't want to think that,
you know everyone to blame people for
that.
But wow.
You know,
I mean obviously we know that's not true
because there's geographic centers in
this country where there's certainly
attracted to,
you know,
but the idea that more of them come
because people are more fucked up and
they're accelerating because our society
is deteriorating.
That's a terrifying thought that we're
responsible for that.
Well,
or,
or even on a one percent level even
that,
that we're responsible for just having
any influence on it.
Not that we created,
but that we even have any barriers as I
discussed in like the 2012 book.
Like the Hopi for instance,
who live in Arizona,
tribes like that may have actually
chosen to live in very difficult
environments where survival is really
like on a knife edge because it forced
them to be able to do things like rain
dances.
So they did it on purpose or do you
think that it.
Is that in or is it that is the result
of them living in this difficult
environment and develop more character?
Well,
it's quite possible because they had a
large choice earlier on of where they
were going to leave and it's possible
they actually chose to leave and live in
very difficult environments because it
forced them to develop their initiatory
and psychic capacity.
The only reason why I'm questioned that
is because back then the resources were
so scarce and you were on foot
essentially,
so if you were on foot,
how much fucking ground can you cover
and how much do you know about other
lands?
You know?
How much do you know about if you move
five hours south doesn't get that cold.
You don't fucking know that.
Actually,
I totally disagree with what you're
saying on both levels.
First of all,
I think that they did.
No,
I mean for instance,
we now understand that there was like a
sign language.
Even native people who didn't speak the
same language could actually communicate
with very highly developed sign
language.
There was all across the continent and
second of all,
what they've discovered is that a lot of
native cultures were actually more like
cultures of abundance and cultures of
scarcity that actually the amount of
work that they had to do today though,
you know,
compared to what we have to do know an
average day,
it was a lot less than.
But that doesn't make match up with your
idea of them moving to a very difficult
environment to stay alive.
Because I'm talking about the hope in
particular,
let's say like,
yeah,
they were like the Tibetan Buddhists of
the native people,
they chose the most difficult spot.
What they state this anywhere as is just
a conclusion or a feeling you have.
No,
it's a theory.
It's a theory.
I mean,
you know,
maybe it's ludicrous,
but,
um,
uh,
it was just inside my visited them for
the book and I read a lot about them
anthropological accounts and so on.
But the whole thing is they would put
themselves through these extraordinary,
uh,
you know,
kind of,
uh,
efforts,
you know,
the,
the Hopi snake clan.
They would go all around the area that
we collect all of the most poisonous
snakes they could possibly find.
Then the men would sit,
you know,
just naked wearing,
going kloss in a circle with their knees
touching.
They would open up all of the snakes in
the middle of the circle and the men
would have to sit entirely still until
all of the snakes had crawled past them.
Wow.
That's pretty fucking wild,
right?
They definitely,
definitely had their shit together when
it came to rites of passage.
You know,
I remember that movie the,
a man called horse.
Do you remember that night incident?
It was a,
it was a,
um,
I forget the guy's name,
the.
He played the father in a gladiator.
Peter O'toole,
I believe it's Peter O'toole.
I might be incorrect.
Anyway,
amazing fucking movie.
But one of the scariest parts of it is
one of these rights of passage that he
has in order to become one with their
tribes and American or a be an
Englishman.
I forget the fucking bills,
but they hung him by his nipples.
You know,
they used to do shit to test you.
Oh,
there's are the,
the sun dances,
they put the,
they lance you through the,
uh,
the pectoral muscles hang you up.
Really.
Is that necessary?
Apparently,
yes.
It's the Indian equivalent of about
teeth straightening I guess,
or botox ingestion or an injection or
something.
Oh,
it's way worse than that.
Are Way better than
rather it's um,
I think,
you know,
just having something like having a bar
Mitzvah,
having some sort of a celebration.
It doesn't even have to be,
you know,
you're hung from a tree by your tits.
It just has to be something where like,
okay,
I,
I pass through the door.
Well,
it's a symbolic.
That's actually what you're saying.
For me it was like a big distinction for
those cultures.
Initiation was actually about going
through some process through which you
would master non ordinary states of
consciousness.
You mean on what would cultures,
the native cultures.
I mean,
initiation was not just a celebration.
You actually had to overcome,
you know,
a life death crisis yet
warrior for them too.
I mean,
you're in a constant state of,
you know,
defending your tribes and you know,
you were,
you had to be able to overcome very,
very terrifying situations even in
hunting.
You know,
they had a makeup man out of you.
Yeah.
But,
but I,
but I think that a lot of it was really
more about learning to have a
disciplined approach to non ordinary
states of states of consciousness to
control states of consciousness.
I mean,
what do you mean by non ordinary to mean
like pod enhanced?
What do you,
I mean obviously pod mushrooms and these
are all native Ios Osca and so on.
But then also things like fasting,
you know,
and being,
not eating for five nights where you're
just sitting on a mountain top or
something or what's the benefit of that?
It's both exactly puts you in exactly
the same kind of state as the
psychoactive substances.
Five fasting for five days.
Those will bring on a visionary,
visionary experiences,
you know,
they were,
and,
and force you to,
you know,
discipline your mind,
be able to withstand,
you know,
ingression this from like the astral
realms.
And so on,
what do you say to people that say that
doing something along the lines of
fasting where it's actually possibly
dangerous to your body and that's what's
causing you to have these experiences.
It's really kind of a silly thing to do
in this day and age where you could
choose other paths to the same sort of
results without damaging your body and
shutting things down.
I don't know enough about nutrition to
tell you whether or not it's healthy,
but I've read a lot of people that start
talking about fasting for days and days,
days and they say it puts strain on you.
It's not good for you.
I mean,
I don't know.
No,
I wouldn't say it's not good for you to
not eat.
It probably isn't.
I don't know.
I know I didn't know a lot of people who
love it and find it to be very helpful.
That actually one of them in terms of
extending the human lifespan,
they found that,
you know,
reducing your caloric intake is,
is,
is the most direct way to do it.
Does that make sense?
To just.
Your body's going at less Rpms,
you know,
a,
a race engines,
not gonna,
not going to last as long.
There's a good episode of Penn and
Teller Bullshit.
Look at the cleansing episode where they
go through like the the diets,
like the lemon detox diets and shit like
that where you don't eat the officer,
go through the colonics and the whole
thing like that.
That the whole thing is,
it's a crock.
Shantelle is bullshit.
Make some excellent points,
but they also make some silly ones
because they.
They want to find the conclusion that
everything is bullshit.
That's what they're doing.
I don't think they dismiss yoga.
I watched them dismiss Yoga.
We're just talking about.
It's just stretching and stretching and
I was like,
wow,
you're crazy.
You've never done a yoga class.
If you do yoga for two hours and tell me
that's just stretching.
Yoga makes you hot.
Yoga makes you.
I've,
I've gotten is high from yoga as I have
from a couple of hits of pot.
No doubt about it.
No doubt.
Like real strong pot.
I've gotten to like body tingling
moments.
Like especially if you take like a real
good class,
like hot yoga where you go real deep
into poses and you really hold them.
Anybody that dismisses that as just
stretching,
you're either not giving me the full
information that you have access to or
you did a really sloppy job of
investigating it,
you know,
you can't just say these fucking Indian
masters that had been doing this shit
for thousands of years or just
stretching and that's why they have
these very specific poses that they
believe activate very specific regions
in the hemispheres of the,
of the Chakras of the body.
You can't just dismiss that a
cat if you want.
I mean,
that's what's so a kind of interesting
and cool about what's happening right
now and how things are so complex.
I mean,
yeah,
you know,
I mean I was looking at a book by this
guy,
Dean Raden,
who studies a psychic phenomena as a
scientist that incident noetic sciences
and we interviewed for a film or read a
book called the Self Aware Universe and
he analyzes a whole century's worth of
data and psychic experience experience.
Statistically.
He even looks at reports from the US
army and the government which support
the existence of psychic phenomena,
of non local communication mind to mind,
which means that consciousness is not
simply brain-based that exist in a
different way now.
But I've also read recently this book by
Richard Wiseman called Para normality,
who believes there was no psychic
phenomena,
you know,
busts every evidence for it,
and,
and in his own way is quite convincing,
you know,
so,
so for me it's,
it's,
um,
it's just makes it a very interesting
time,
you know,
where you can approach anything and
analytically rip it apart and find the
weak spots.
But,
but maybe what,
uh,
what's missing from Penn and teller and
Richard Wiseman's understanding is the
sense that a intention is somehow a
fundamental aspect of the universe,
you know,
so,
so if your intention is to,
you know,
take something apart,
desecrated,
ignore it,
you know,
and so on,
you can do of that for sure.
You know,
but,
um,
but within there you've kind of missed a
subtle key that actually makes a life
worth having in a way.
Well,
intention is aware and you can be aware
of it in a very tangible form in the art
of standup comedy.
It's you cannot be thinking about
something different.
Say something else and have the people
react to it.
They won't.
It won't work.
It's a weird thing.
You could have the joke worded
correctly.
You could say it with the right
intonation you get,
but if your mind is an intuit,
they can smell it.
It's the weirdest fucking thing in the
world.
The a connection that you have with an
audience.
It could be an audience of 200 or it can
be an audience of a thousand.
If you've reached that full connection,
it is like a giant mass hypnosis.
There is some sort of a relationship
that you had with these people and if
somehow or another something hits you,
you remember something or something
bothers you or you think about an
argument that you got in with your
girlfriend or a bill,
you forgot to pay her.
Any distraction that makes you feel in a
negative way.
Even if you're saying the words the same
night,
the audience will feel it.
They will feel it and they will back off
you.
You can feel it.
You could feel them go.
He's not,
he's not engaged.
It's a religion man.
It's real.
You can't tell me it's not.
I've always said that,
you know,
I do my best to,
uh,
write standup.
I sit down,
I do my best to put in the time to be
there to make the writing happen,
and I do in the time when I perform
enough so that I get onstage that I'm
really comfortable and relaxed.
But ultimately at the end of the day,
I'm not exactly sure how that shit is
even coming out.
I don't know where it's coming from.
I don't know what's happening and when
I'm on stage,
when I'm completely locked in,
I am as much a passenger as I am the
person who steers it.
And as long as that works,
as long as I'm in that groove and the
audiences in that group,
the whole thing will go seamlessly.
But one little hiccup,
one little bad thought,
one little error,
one little stress point,
and everybody hops off the the,
the bride and weights and looks at you
and goes,
you're going to get this thing going
again.
And Yeah,
get back in.
Everybody gets back in,
we're okay.
We're okay.
Do you know what you're doing now?
I know what I'm doing now they can tell.
And that's a psychic connection.
That's a legit tangible,
psychic connection that when you're on
stage,
you feel it from the crowd.
You feel like waves of positive and
negative.
You literally feel the energy and you
can say that,
right?
You've said you've had really good sets
on stage and you've had jokes that
bombed and you've met people angry at
you.
You felt that,
right?
Don't you feel it like a wave?
It,
it,
it affects you.
Just like anything like getting hit by a
snowball.
You know,
like if you got a bad joke on state,
if you got,
that's the worst.
If he had a bad joke on stage,
but uh,
and it would hit you before you were
like having a great day.
After that you're,
you're having the worst day ever.
You just got hit in the face with
Villanova.
You life is the exact same life.
Literally.
None of the hard details
have changed and yet you feel you
fucking loser,
you know,
because these people have let you know,
you have not given us what we want.
Is this weird sort of an exchange that's
going on because I haven't had no.
CIS and Trans are things that are
operating like much of the time,
you know.
Have you ever watched a massive doses
show?
Yeah,
I did watch my college one,
so thanks.
Sorry.
They used to have them all the time in
Boston at the,
um,
there's a place called the comedy
connection.
Every week they had this guy,
Frank Santos,
who would do a hypnotist comedy show
that seemed like bullshit until you saw
it a few times.
And when you saw it a few times you
would realize,
oh my God,
these people are really fucking under.
It's so weird.
And not everybody,
he would know,
he would go up to the people that
weren't and he'd look at them and go,
okay,
you get off the stage when he pulled the
people off the stage.
But the people that were up there,
for whatever reason,
he found their,
their,
their hack code and got into their food.
I tend to look at most of our
politicians and uh,
you know,
news anchors is kind of a illuminati
sorcerers who use a transit gnosis to
keep people in a,
in a,
in a lower state of consciousness,
loaded state of suggestibility,
Illuminati.
I hate black wizards.
He got,
he got robbed by a black wizard guy
dressed up like a wizard,
put a gun in his chest,
sort of guide a fake beard on.
So he called them black wizard
socks.
Man,
there's this guy at my starbucks and I
feel so bad for him because he,
he totally reminds me of him,
that guy that robbed me.
And every time I fucking walk in there,
I'm just like,
damn,
I'm fucking totally just eyeing this guy
more than I normally would.
I somebody waiting in line and I'll just
be like,
what's that guy doing?
Like a dog that used to bite you?
Yeah,
exactly.
And He,
I've caught eyes with them like three
times.
I feel so fucking bad about this.
I might have to switch starbucks because
of it.
Just switched to our bugs.
Yeah,
I'll just do that.
Just,
you know,
I was Kinda mad.
Yeah.
But then he's like,
he's kicking me out of the starbucks.
You know,
what,
if it is him to the idea that you
somehow or another manifestation
that is where things get really spooky,
you know,
the people that believe that you
manifest every single action in your
life and that you have some sort of
alternative that really you,
it's more like the,
uh,
I liked the Vedanta perspective of the.
Basically there's like a singular
consciousness,
you know,
we're kind of like,
we're,
we're part of the projection,
okay,
what,
what is the way?
If that is the case,
how can I avoid some horrible bullshit
in my life?
Can I just have to do the right thing
and be super nice and always go in a
positive direction and you can't draw
like I'm starting to think that you
can't control if you can't afford it,
just ignore it or what's the bullshit
that you can't ignore?
Oh,
well,
just a like life,
life and death.
People for whatever,
for whatever
right now in all my life,
for whatever reason right now,
the last year to two years in my life
have been the most psychotic and crazy,
but yet I've also been paused.
Please,
please pause.
Please.
The most successful place
he's been dating porn stars.
Okay?
What the fuck man.
Already know what I'm saying.
I also want what I'm saying.
Dog fucking die.
I've also got mugged at gun.
I've also fucking a million other things
that lately that has been happening that
in my whole life never has.
My life has been boring as fuck.
You know,
and now I'm having horrible things
happen to me at the same time as I'm
having the best time of my life.
Well,
you know,
maybe that maybe there's something wrong
in the formula of how you're interacting
with the grid.
Maybe there's something wrong.
What if you had to look,
forget it.
Forget it.
Forget your life.
Put it away.
You're not even you.
If you had to look at how many people
were taking a lot of people,
that's how the government spends money.
Hopefully not one of my friends I've
got.
Please hold
place if you were not you.
Okay.
Forget about the emotional attachment
that you have all day.
All your issues.
How would you fix you?
What would you say?
You know,
the one thing that we would like to
correct about Brian would be x.
What would it be?
What's the number one thing?
Yeah.
If you had,
if you could,
instead of working at something,
if you could just correct something
about your behavior,
the way you think about things or the
way you look at the world or anything.
What would it be?
Uh,
did not throw.
Come on walls.
Okay.
What if you just stopped doing?
I really don't.
Like I never think you don't believe
that any of you on myself.
I don't feel like I have any flaws.
I don't overthink it.
My,
my,
my personal.
This is what I'm trying to
gets it.
This is what I'm trying to get to.
I don't know if it's either or.
I don't know.
If you look,
there's babies that are killed in drive
bys and when I hear about that I go,
well that doesn't know how the fuck does
that work?
What's going on there?
He knows the baby.
Have some negative thoughts that haven't
been.
Then I think about it and I think about
all the positive things that have
happened in my life and all the positive
things that I know have manifested
themselves through a certain type of
thinking,
a certain ethic,
a certain way of looking at the world
and I wonder if it is either or or if
it's a combination of things.
You know what I'm saying?
Daniel?
I like tuned that for a second.
Sorry.
I just personally think that I'm trying
to kill.
The only choice we ever have is to look
at the bright side of the or the crappy
side.
So why not just always look at the
bright side.
Yeah,
but you were looking at the end of
civilization.
Just looking at the moment.
I was looking at your dues statue and
your Voodoo doll and you're kind of
getting your,
your,
your sort of demon that represented
this.
Well,
no,
I'm actually,
the Balinese stuff has just.
I've always been fascinated by eastern
art.
I think it's beautiful and I,
I think it's amazing how cheap it is.
You could get this amazing.
Thank you.
Because that's a haunted.
That's why.
Because there's little kids that made it
as a four year old kids.
Made it a little ginger kid
artwork.
Man.
I love this one of those things.
I'm not really into like,
you know,
I've,
I've bought paintings before and I don't
kind of get a lot of what people are
really into.
So there's some.
I was at a,
um,
a guy's house once and uh,
he had a picture on the wall and I go,
oh,
did you couldn't make that.
And this guy goes,
oh no,
that's a little bit,
but uh,
that's like $30,000
and I went,
what the fuck are you talking about?
It looked like some painting on some are
ripped pieces of cardboard that were
randomly stuck in a beautiful frame and
I really thought that it was something
that a kid did.
So I don't get that
there needs to be done one that's just
that kind of shit like Gold Buddhists,
but more of a corporate place that's
just super cheap.
Like that could be like $10.
I want to buy a dragon mass,
but I went feathers.
I want to be cheap,
you know,
because like that kind of Shit's
popular.
Everyone likes that kind of shit.
Why don't they make it like a walmart of
that shit,
Brian?
I think you're missing.
I also think that they should make cat
food and dog food into one food.
They could probably easily do that.
I don't think they can.
I think they have different dietary
needs.
They can all eat chicken.
Right.
Okay.
So put that on the list.
If you want to go check it all.
Even bazell put chicken base.
This guy is brutal to work with.
I'm sorry bro.
I brought a serious man in here.
It's fucking New York Times crazy.
You're talking nonsense about cat and
dog food.
You Lazy contract and go out and buy the
cat food,
the dog food and stop fucking up the
shots.
Eating dog food and my dogs eating the
cat food.
Wanting to just make you got a problem
that you've got to pat
girlfriends.
You fuck this guy.
He's.
He gets a new relationship and it's
like,
oh my God,
we should get a kid and they go out and
they get a fucking dog and then the
girls dump them and he's got a God damn.
It's like watching lower for nanny.
I'm like,
daddy warbucks
brock.
Sorry man,
this.
This is a serious podcast,
but it's also.
It's also a comedy podcast.
The good news is we've had an excellent
conversation.
I guarantee you a lot of people will buy
your shit.
So.
Hey Joe.
I was at the comedy store and there's.
There's that whole coast that goes thing
that happened at the fucking ghosts
anywhere.
I know,
but I'm so tired of,
do you believe in ghosts?
Of course.
Oh my God.
Jo.
I was,
I was sitting in the green room behind
the main room.
We were all smoking hot.
Doesn't know that ghosts are real.
I've collected so many incredible
stories about ghosts.
Really.
What do they do?
Uh,
I mean,
a friend of mine,
her,
uh,
friend's brother had had committed
suicide and she was sleeping in the
house where he had died and she had a
dream that they were having sex and she
woke up from the dream and um,
her,
her covers were up and there was this
kind of like spirit figure over her.
And as soon as she began to open her
eyes,
it dissipated.
There's no way that could have been a
dream inside of dream.
Of course,
it could have been anything.
Of course it could be,
but I'm gonna have,
you know,
I mean,
we,
you know,
because there's no,
how are you going to verify this type of
thing?
What I've collected a whole number of
anecdotes told to me by people and
observing their,
you know,
their,
their state,
their efforts to kind of understand it,
to fathom at my own experiences.
Also I've had similar,
you know,
it's,
I,
I think that there's no doubt that,
you know,
probably,
psychic energy collects in physical
environments and when people are no
longer there,
if they have a stake in that environment
and they are not finished with their
business in the world that they out,
you know,
or some pieces of the energy of it
and resentment or something,
some sort of a bad energy is enough to
keep a resident
do.
When my father died,
I mean he had a loft,
was full of his paintings and
sculptures,
you know,
the last.
And he had a big freight elevator.
Like I was working with two guys
bringing his stuff out.
As we're bringing out the last shipment
of,
of his sculptures down in the freight
elevator.
Suddenly the light bulb and it just
totally popped and we were in darkness
and you know,
we were all looking at it.
We,
nobody had touched it,
you know,
somehow that psychic energy that was,
that was constellated between us and
him,
you know,
caused this thing to happen,
or the light bulb I was Joe,
I was in the phone call that you going
to have to make today.
To me,
there are certain things when you feel
the synchronicity,
it's like,
it's like a click,
you know,
and it's like you have an intuitive,
acceptance that uh,
you're,
you're being shown a little bit of like
the fabric of space time making a little
bit of a ripple or something.
I was in the green room
seriously with like eight people in the
comedy store to started the company
store,
if you didn't know for just Fyi was
Ciro's nightclub and it was a bugsy
Siegel's hanging out in Hollywood and a
lot of people allegedly were murdered
there.
And every single person who has been
there for more than x amount of years
has some sort of a ghost story.
Every one of the waitresses has
something managers have something,
you know,
how much of it is psychosomatic,
how much of his suggestion,
how much does the other comics,
and I was sitting there with like eight
other people were just smoking weed,
hanging out,
talking,
and suddenly the door sounded like
somebody shot a gun through like,
it didn't feel like sound,
like somebody just shook it or kicked
it.
It seemed way more powerful than that to
the fact that I think everybody in the
room kinda got down was like,
what the fuck was that?
And we all Kinda got down like on the
couches and on the ground as if we all
thought for sure that was a gunshot,
right?
We'll lose.
Let me stop right there.
And then of course,
old ass building.
Here's what's important.
This is a building for the 19 twenties.
That's fucking fault line,
right?
Those buildings shift and every now and
then they shift and they literally,
and it'll,
it'll make a noise.
I've been in the car when it makes
noise.
Okay.
It's old married.
Fuck.
I'm not saying that it wasn't a ghost.
Now the most likely explanation is that
right?
I thought it was another comic and he's
just like the secret,
like,
Oh yeah,
we take this plunger and then we just
hit it as hard as we can
let comedy secret.
I'm sorry,
my grandparents lived in a uh,
supposedly haunted house and I stayed
there with them in,
uh,
in Newark,
New Jersey and it was on north ninth
street and there was a guy who actually
died in the house and he was a guy who
was renting a room there and he died and
they,
they always thought that this house was
haunted though because the house was
always making noises,
but it's a fucking house that was built
in like 19.
Oh nine,
you know,
it's an old fucking house and when
you're dealing in a place like New
Jersey that's moist all the time and it
rains all the time and then it gets hot
in the summer and cold in the winter she
would is like,
you know,
it's an piece of,
construction.
It couldn't,
it constricts,
it expands depending on the moisture in
the air,
depending on it being cold or hot and
the car,
the old houses like that.
They make a lot of fucking noise in the
creek.
There always were clock and people are
just fucking places or it's an old house
man,
but I'm not completely averse to the
idea of ghosts,
but a lot of people that talk about
ghosts are full of shit.
Well I just think if there is goes,
there would be an easy way to prove it
and we've talked about it before.
You just go to somebody that's like
wifes got died in a rape and you go to
his grave and just or her grave and just
start humping her grave or something.
You know,
if there was such thing as that goes,
goes would come out and be like,
dude,
what the fuck?
They wouldn't want to indulge you and
your nonsense.
Maybe you would hit the wrong if maybe
maybe it's not something that can easily
be tuned in.
Maybe it's like the northern lights,
like the idea of,
you know,
you can't capture the northern lights
and put it in the fucking beam and
blasted on Manhattan.
The northern lights are,
you know,
it's a theory that some sort of a thing
that moves and pulsates in the sky,
you know,
maybe that's what like a ghost is like a
very minor version of that.
Like it doesn't have a rhyme or reason
for when it exists or doesn't exist,
but it doesn't have a rhyme and reason.
It's just we don't understand those laws
yet.
You say that violates nature.
Just that our understanding of natural
law is limited by our,
by our mental conception,
by the type of science that we've
constructed and so on.
Are you convinced,
I mean what like when you look at the
evidence of ghosts and not go shows,
if you looked at.
Wait,
wait,
what evidence are you talking about?
Do we have any solid evidence ever that
there was a ghost or just speculation?
Almost entirely speculation.
There's no scientific evidence.
Well,
it doesn't mean that they're not real.
Because if you think about what a ghost
is,
if it goes to something that's not in
this dimension and sort of flits in and
out of it,
and how do you measure that?
I mean sciences,
you know,
everybody says,
well,
science says there are no ghosts or
there's no scientific evidence that goes
will science was not really designed to
measure shit like ghosts.
Science is designed to measure like how
much does lead way.
You know what happens when a star goes
supernova observable things.
When you get something like a ghost.
If a ghost was real and it seems
incredibly rare phenomenon that depended
on some really exotic conditions,
how the fuck you.
I can imagine that I'm giving the offer.
If there's any ghosts listening,
they can fucking raped me tonight and
they could just rate my ass all day long
with sticks.
And if it happens,
I'll let you know.
I've got news for you.
If they're going to come here from
another guy can do better than me.
I mean for instance,
there is like um,
decent and interesting evidence around a
reincarnation really.
There was a book,
a person's name in Stevens,
was a professor at University of
Virginia to like 2,500
page book called neurobiology and
reincarnation intersect and he found all
around the world there were children who
had spontaneous recall of past lives and
often very specific like an India.
They'd be like,
you know,
I was,
I
lived in this town.
I'm,
my wife had this name.
I had two kids.
So in a number of cases he found these
kids and he went back to the towns and
they talked about and,
and they found this family and establish
that there had been this,
this connection and,
and um,
the sense of familiarity.
No,
no genetic,
no genetic line,
no genetic link.
And sometimes the kids would even have
like a pronounced birthmark,
like a birthmark on the neck or
something.
And it turned out that the previous
incarnation perhaps had died of a wound
to the neck and a fight or something
like that.
Is it possible that the connection is an
abstract one that you know,
that they,
they,
they haven't met it yet,
but that yet there's not a,
a balanced value to learn to experiences
that are transferred through genetics,
like instincts and that perhaps some
instincts that we have a really like
things go wrong.
You learn from them.
That's why you're afraid of cats.
Mean kids are afraid of them.
Seven year old kid and suddenly out of
nowhere saying,
you know,
I have a wife and Agora,
I have two kids
to see them.
Yeah,
this is.
But this is my point isn't impossible.
I mean,
isn't it possible that somehow or
another that there is a,
a memory that through whatever,
a mutation or whatever extreme condition
or weird circumstance as far as like
physical biology becomes a more potent
one and that this as it is transferred
through through generations awakens this
memory awakens this,
this,
this experience that someone who shared
these genetics,
oh so many generations ago actually did
have.
Then all of a sudden,
for whatever strange,
if there's any,
um,
idea that,
you know,
genetic material,
it could have,
could have hold memory like that.
Well,
what about memes?
What are the,
what about the idea that even racism can
be transferred genetically?
I mean,
that's a really kind of a,
a widely considered idea.
Almost unprovable,
but I considered by mainstream science.
Yes.
I think a lot of those,
those,
those ideas about all these things being
inherited by the genetics being this
kind of master molecule are actually
being kind of challenged right now by
the emerging biology of epigenetics,
which is recognizing that,
you know,
awareness actually begins at the
boundary of the cell where chemical
signals are exchanged.
There's a kind of cognitive process that
happens even at the permeable boundary
of the cell as some signals are allowed
in and some are ignored or rejected and
that's what's allowed in actually then
influences how the genetic material
expresses itself and reproduces itself.
That actually it's not so much the
genetic material is the master molecule.
It's more as if the whole cell is a unit
of cognition or awareness.
This is very much thinking of people
like a Varella,
but is this a theory or they have done.
Okay,
well,
they haven't done it,
but everything was counting.
Yeah.
I mean,
this is a look at the biologist Bruce
Lipton.
He has a book called a biology beyond
belief.
Really looking at how,
um,
you know,
consciousness and awareness began even
at a cellular level and how that in
itself influences and inflects how the
genetic material expresses itself.
That the genes are not master molecules.
The whole idea it,
it's so fascinating.
The idea of,
you know,
I mean w w what,
what instincts when we're,
we're,
do we instincts come from.
I mean,
is it all from one initial source,
you know,
stay away from fire.
You get scared when you see snakes.
I mean,
these are all learned impressions and in
our,
our material,
the material that makes human beings are
certain things that you show people and
children when they're really young,
have certain fears and notions of the
bogeyman and the,
you know,
the,
the monster that lives in the woods and
the things in the dark and,
and a lot of these are imprinted from
being killed by Jaguars from some
protocol hominid that lived 5,000
or 5 million years ago there got killed
by Jaguars.
And those,
those instincts are still tingling in
the background noise of our mind.
That's possible.
And that could also be explained.
You ever get into like rupert sheldrake
his ideas around the morphogenic field,
but knowing when their parents coming
home,
so maybe there was this species
encounter that was like a near death
encounter for humanity and it left this
morphogenic field of,
of,
of fear and terror around the snake,
around the Jaguar or something like
that.
Yeah.
Well we are certainly moving.
I mean if I had to guess into some sort
of a state where that becomes more and
more aware now,
wouldn't you agree?
What becomes more and more aware that
the state that have this
interconnectedness,
this morphogenetic field,
this idea that you know,
that we are living in social or a
complex meshwork of biological life and
natural natural laws and physics and
space and radiation and all of it
together combined by and it sort of
people are realizing it now like way
more than ever before.
I mean,
when I was a kid,
there was no talk.
There was nothing along these lines.
Yeah,
it's extraordinary.
And,
and maybe that is pointing towards the
kind of next phase of evolution as a
species.
I mean,
do you think it's technology and it's
going to do that?
Well,
I think we have to look at technology
itself as an aspect of the evolution of
consciousness.
You know,
that actually like we're,
we're a tool using and toolmaking
species.
We make a new tool and then we look at
the tool with the instrument we've made.
It reflects us back at ourself and then
it gives us new metaphors for
understanding ourselves.
Then it allows us to make another more
advanced tool and that creates a whole
new set of metaphor.
So now we've gotten to the point in our
tool creation and tool using or this
feedback loop is happening faster and
faster,
so we're having,
we're,
we're better,
but it's still a tool as a projection of
our consciousness,
of our thought into the material realm,
which then gives us information about
ourselves,
which then leads us to create another
tool which also advances and evolves our
consciousness.
In that
process,
do you ever get to the point where you,
uh,
you,
you get upset that you have a connection
with these,
these items,
these technological items like phones or
do do not regret it ever?
Or do you just accept it,
enjoy it?
Like I think it's very fascinating and
it's also as we've been,
part of what we'll be doing with reality
sandwich is bringing people down to work
with indigenous Shamans and elders.
So recently we went down to the Columbia
and worked with these Kogi guys from the
mountains in Columbia.
And when we hung out with them,
we were in a place without any
electricity for eight days.
So no phone,
no computer after like a day and a half.
I was like,
what did I want all that stuff for
again,
like,
this is so much nicer now.
Suddenly you can see the stars at night.
You're like light a fire and the fire
goes out and you go to sleep.
You wake up at dawn.
I mean,
you know,
I think that actually we,
we may find that we've gone way too far
on this technological path that we
thought that we've had a kind of,
um,
in a sense the religious belief of
modern society is linear technological
progress leading to some kind of
singularity or transformation that we
may actually back up from that and be
like,
well,
wait a second.
Where is this stuff leading to?
I mean,
actually I have more plastics in my
tissues.
You know,
my eyes are going bad from looking at
these tiny screens.
You know,
why is life constantly mediated by
glowing rectangular screens anyway?
That actually we might want to retract
from this technological path and develop
in a different direction,
which doesn't mean rejecting technology.
It's more about mastering our
projections rather than,
rather than feeling that we always have
to get a meshed in them.
And then move in that direction,
is it sort of like riding a bike too
fast and you're going downhill and you
go,
oh fuck,
like it's good to ride this bike.
But I've gotten kind of away from my own
biological control of this situation.
Well,
that's certainly what's happened to us
as a species.
I mean,
um,
you know,
in every level we've been seduced by our
technological production projections in
a sense.
We've lost our grounding on the planet.
What do you ever consider the idea that
when some sort of a weird symbiotic
relationship where it's our job as the
host to create this environment?
Where are the parasite,
which is technology?
There's new life form that we've created
to exist in that ultimately discard us
because it is the next stage of not
organic life,
but of consciousness and that
consciousness.
The next stage of consciousness will be
artificial consciousness created by
this,
this consciousness that was created by
biological life and that we are only
here to usher in the next stage.
That next stage is in electronic form.
A stage that doesn't have emotions or
nonsense or
any of this shit that is not the way I
look at it.
And we don't,
we don't.
Well,
we don't,
we don't know.
We have no,
we have no reason at this point to
really believe that,
you know,
an artificial intelligence can become
conscious in the way we are.
I mean,
machines may have,
you know,
a form,
I mean everything.
We have a form of sentience but,
but,
uh,
you know,
we may still have a very important role
if we're,
if we're in our proper state,
you know,
in,
in the cosmic unfolding.
But should we,
I mean if,
or a,
a step along the way,
what,
who's to say that that step eventually a
continues along a biological train.
Maybe it really is truly our destiny to
create some sort of an artificial life
that's not burdened down by our,
our,
our monkey DNA and all the instincts
that we needed to evolve to this point
with the curiosity that would allow us
to make something as crazy as artificial
intelligence.
And maybe we're just the carriers maybe
where the carriers of the disease that
eventually takes off and,
and.
Well,
I guess part of what I would suggest to
you is that,
you know,
part of our opportunity right now is to
become cocreative with the evolutionary
process.
And that in a way means that we have to
step into a much more responsible and
mature role where we actually become
participants and,
and in a way we still kind of enjoy the
spectacle of our own alienation and our
own potential destruction.
So we kind of enjoy kind of like
elaborating the,
the,
the sort of futuristic mythologies of
how our technology is going to overwhelm
us or devour us.
I mean that might be the case,
but all we really know at this point is
that we have,
will,
we have intelligence,
we have consciousness and we're not
using it very well.
So the first thing I would think that we
would want to try to do is use it very,
very effectively to see what type of
better situation we can rapidly create.
You know,
rather than fobbing off our
responsibility onto,
oh,
there's going to be this technological
thing or it's too late,
we fucked the planet,
or there's some new age psychic children
coming along.
All that stuff to me is just bullshit
ass dodges.
That basically is other ways that we're
avoiding taking full responsibility for
the planetary situation that we as a
species have created,
which is for me is really the only way
we're going to possibly create a better
world in the time that we have before
things go to hell.
Well,
I do agree that as a person who's a big
proponent of team people,
you know,
I definitely advocate the idea of us
figuring out what the fuck we are doing
and making it better for all of us and
our relationship with the planet.
But to me that doesn't seem like you're
fobbing that off.
But the,
considering the possibility that we are
merely here as many other parasites and
hosts are in this world.
And you look at like grasshoppers where
there's they're infected by aquatic
worms and aquatic worms trick the
grasshopper into jumping into water and
the grasshopper drowns.
Well,
so the world can be born out of it.
I personally think that we actually are
infected but by a parasitical agency.
And I would say that agency is something
like the dominator empire complex,
the,
the sense that we have of separation
from nature,
the sense that we have the right to,
you know,
annihilate ecosystems,
dominate ecosystems,
control other people.
The whole,
the whole trip of empire,
the slavery.
I mean there's still tons of slavery
around the world domination of women
that,
that's,
that's the parasite that's eating us
alive right now.
And that's where,
you know,
if we can go through our entire
initiatory process,
we,
we can,
we can begin to,
you know,
find the antidote or the cure to that.
But it's not about,
you know,
from my perspective,
like giving it up to technology,
you know,
as an amazing thing.
It's more like reclaiming our,
our human capacity.
And for me,
that,
that's really where the,
the knowledge of the indigenous people
is not,
you know,
folk tale.
It's not silly,
it's not worthless.
It's actually something that,
that,
you know,
those of us who care about you seeking
to,
you know,
move into an evolutionary framework.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
they,
they have,
they have tools and gifts for us.
And that's why part of what I've been
trying to do over the last couple,
well a lot of my work but,
but now in a different way is build
bridges to,
to the indigenous people and their
knowledge systems,
you know.
So I'm working now with the Kogi in
Columbia and also
the sequoia from Ecuador.
Uh,
wha.
What,
what I meant by that was not that it has
to be,
it almost like when I,
when I,
when I look at the relationship that we
have with,
with technology and I look at the
relationship that different parents
sites and different hosts have it just
as a consideration.
You have to think about the fact that
our society is completely obsessed with
pushing innovation.
We're completely obsessed and I often
look at the dominator culture,
what you describe,
and I say,
well,
you know,
you're right.
I mean that is a huge fucking problem.
War and the domination of other
countries and battling for resources,
but what do you say to people that say
that there's no way you can have a
society that,
that reaches this particular height this
fast without that as a byproduct and
that in fact the reason why people push
so hard to innovate and to create new
things and conquer new,
new,
new new boundaries both scientifically
and socially,
is that it's all almost a byproduct of
this desire to innovate and create and
produce this next thing and that this is
all a part of us creating some
artificial thing.
Some intelligence.
I,
I think we have to.
We have to,
we have to break the trance of
technology,
which is not to say that we reject
but we have to break that trance that
somehow,
you know,
there's this linear technological
progress is necessarily,
you know,
bringing us to something super amazing.
And for me,
the shift in the future is more to a
kind of psycho technical phase of
development.
By that I mean that,
you know,
if you do,
if you've had the DMT and the Ayahuasca
experiences,
the yoga experiences and so on,
you,
you recognize there are these vast
dimensions,
you know,
within the psyche that are basically
unknown incontinence and,
and in a sense that for me is where the
action is going to lie for us in the
future,
you know,
as well as potentially exploring other
planets,
other solar systems and all this stuff.
But,
but at the moment we really more need to
get control of our thought projections.
And the only way to do that is to
undergo an initiatory process that
involves,
you know,
kind of getting into our unconscious
patterns.
Initiatory process.
What do you mean?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean like,
you know,
hanging,
fasting or hanging by your packs for six
days or taking Iowasca,
you know,
for a couple of weeks until you know
you're,
you're so nauseous.
Did you can't believe it,
but still vision.
The insights keep coming up and they
begin to heal.
Have your,
um,
you know,
pathetic humanness,
you save the setting humanness,
but then why are you,
you completely averse to the idea that
we are just here to develop something
else,
which I mean,
we obviously are just a step along the
way and will be unrecognizable few
million years.
Think that what we're here to do
develop is,
uh,
you know,
integrity,
consciousness and willpower.
And once we've developed that,
then we can think about what else we may
develop at the moment.
We don't have that.
We just think we do.
Do you feel happy?
Do you feel happy that you're.
Um,
and I,
I believe you are one of the people that
sort of an agent of this sort of,
uh,
I believe right now,
currently we're in a very unusual age of
enlightenment.
And I think that the,
uh,
the,
the level of enlightenment that we've
achieved a culturally over the last
year.
Certainly not everybody,
not last year,
last decade,
certainly not over everybody,
but generally has been more than
anything that I can ever remember in my
lifetime.
And people like you that are pushing
these ideas and people like you that are
trying to challenge the way people view
things and the standard standard,
a predetermined patterns of behavior we
seem to have come to accept you're a
part of moving this thing along these.
These kind of discussions are part of
moving this thing along where people in
college or people who are getting their
first jobs,
people were starting their own first
business versus they're stopping and
they're reconsidering the direction that
they move forward and what their motives
are and whether or not they're just
caught up in momentum.
Yeah,
man,
I feel extremely humble and lucky.
Do you feel obligated?
I feel tremendous obligation and
responsibility to,
um,
do what I can to help out,
you know?
So what is there a way to stop this?
What,
what is the number one problem that we
have?
If we have a urine for destruction and
we're constantly.
The number one problem that we have is
that consciousness and subjectivity are
mass produced by a system that is
basically keeping us in a state of a,
you know,
pacivity and ignorance
system.
A natural system is that system there
because like everything else,
like the way Alpha wolves treat Beta
wolves,
that,
that system is almost set up in place so
that there is an antagonist.
Sure.
It's a,
I see it as an evolutionary process and
just as like,
you know,
the,
the embryo has to push against the shell
and finally breakthrough,
you know,
or doesn't,
um,
inspired by an antagonist.
You,
you,
Ali,
you needed frazier.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean,
and,
uh,
you know,
we definitely have a,
um,
you know,
a powerful military industrial,
corporate empire complex that has sunk
its roots into our subconscious
processes and,
and our psychology and it is going to
require,
it requires a lot of disciplined effort
to recognize how it is,
how it is operating through us on so
many different levels.
And then begin to turn it around from
within.
That's the facts,
pitches.
That's about it.
That's all you're going to absorb.
I haven't done this.
This is an awesome conversation.
Thank you very much for coming over
here.
And my pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
Everything that I thought it would be
plus more if anybody needs to get ahold
of you or check out your stuff,
which should they do and what did,
what did you hand me here?
I'll give you a quick rundown.
Evolver.net
as our social network all over dot and
they have the evolve or social movement.
We have about 50 groups around the world
now.
Mostly in the US who beat up every
month.
We do consciousness raising.
We create a theme that could be the
future of psychedelics.
It could be extra terrestrials,
it could be sustainability or
permaculture.
We use those as both gathering points
where people raise consciousness and
learn,
but then also nexus points for
communities to build.
How long have you been doing evolver?
That's about,
uh,
it's been about three years.
You emailed me about this a long time
ago.
His first sign,
but I'm so overwhelmed by me too.
Don't worry about it though.
So it's like a facebook,
like a psychedelic facebook kind of it,
it's a way for,
you know,
for a kind of global community that's
trying to understand this new paradigm.
And move into it to reach out to each
other.
And then self organized.
Has Anybody ganged my name?
My screen name?
Can I get my ice cream?
We'll give you a beautiful.
Yeah.
And then we have a web magazine Reality
Sandwich Sandwich [inaudible] dot com.
[inaudible] DOT com.
We're doing live webinars.
We just did one on shamanism practices
with Alberto Villoldo.
So that's evolver intensives.com.
And now we're doing a line of books that
include this book here.
Jose Aguila says book manifesto for the
newest sphere,
which is about this idea of a transition
from the biosphere two,
the noosphere.
Nice.
And what is this,
right?
You buy books and everything like that.
Yeah,
for sure.
I books I books,
so evolver additions.com
and there's probably some other stuff on
unify earth.com
is this idea for this December 21st 2012
global event that people can actually
sign up there.
A resource.
What is that again?
This idea to use a search.
What is the name of the site?
Unify earth.
Unified.
Unified Earth Dot com.
Also,
if you're into books,
breaking over the head was how I was
introduced to Daniel.
It's a great book and I read half of
Questo Quando.
I am a fucking add retired though and I
put it down.
I'll pick it up again.
Now that we've had such an awesome
conversation,
Daniel Pinchbeck on twitter,
please follow him on twitter along with
following red band and follow the death
squad on itunes.
It's a fantastic podcast collection of
comedian podcast collections depo on
yesterday.
Stephen was on yesterday.
There's a great show with John Repin
John from that.
He just started doing.
There's.
Freddy Lockhart has a show called what's
good now.
There's already should.
Fear.
Has a great show called the skeptic
tank.
Thompson and his woman Christina have
the,
your mom's house.
And so there's a lot of great podcasts
on there.
It's a lot of fun and solve of course.
All free of the Verizon Wireless Center.
October seventh.
Me and Joey Diaz and probably already
too.
I haven't talked to him,
but the tickets just went on sale today.
So,
uh,
um,
we'll be there October seven.
Thank you very much Mr.
Pinchbeck through you guys.
I appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
To the fleshlight,
go to Joe Rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight.
Entering the code name,
Bro.
This is the first show you've ever been
on,
sponsored by the fleshlight?
Yes.
What did the flashlight do?
I get for sure.
We're trying to combine seriousness,
legitimate thinking,
and completely ridiculous bullshit
altogether in one soup to let people
know,
enjoy it.
Enjoy it bitches.
It ain't gonna last.
Thank you very much.
Mr Pinchbeck to um,
on a Saturday,
the August,
September.
Rather the 10th.
Yeah.
No.
Saturday is the 10th.
Yeah.
Saturday the 10th a Tim Ferriss is
coming by and the 11th is Anthony
Bordain.
Alright.
Thank you very much.
Love you bitches.
And a big kiss.
Thank you.
Bye Bye.